fou moi qui a toujours eu peur de de
quitter euh le navire ce monde navire
exactement et ben vous savez quoi
j'étais rassuré ah par qu'apparemment il
y a un autre bail derrière je sais pas
si je seraai 86e au padle mais bon euh
c'est déjà pas mal euh on passe à
l'histoire du jour on va évoquer cette
histoire qui a fait énormément réagir
tout est partie de cette vidéo vu de
plus de 5 millions de fois sur les
réseaux c'est un enfant de 11 ans qui
aurait été frappé et tranglé par un
policier de la BAC à la gare du Nord à
Paris euh parce qu'il aurait pris un
chocolat dans le sac de sa maman il
aurait été confondu avec un pick pocket
par les policiers une histoire
incroyable dans un instant Suzanne sa
maman sera avec nous euh pour nous
raconter cette histoire à peine croyable
regardez les images tournées juste après
cette terrible scène regardez là il
vient d'agresser mon fils il a étringlé
mon fils parce que il voulait ouvrir le
sac de mon ami il a cru qu'il voulait Il
agressé mon fils il l'a mis par terre
regardez c'est la bague et ils disent
excusez-moi excusez-moi je vais porter
ple bonsoir Suzanne bonsoir ça va bien
Suzanne oui ça va merci d'être là et
vous êtes denu avec une une amie c'est
ça il aime exactement merci alors vous
êtes la maman donc de deux enfants un
grand de 11 ans et un plus petit de de 4
ans jeudi dernier il est environ 16h
vous êtes à la gare du Nord de Paris
c'est ça c'est ça donc tout se passe
bien vous et et là qu'est-ce qui se
passe on attendait notre train pour
rentrer sur l'île
et j'étais au téléphone avec mon avocat
pour une autre
affaire au moment de au moment pendant
que j'étais au téléphone mon fils a
ouvert la poche de mon sac cadeau pour
pour prendre du chocolat mais le
chocolat était rangé dans un autre sac
du coup il a refermé la poche et voilà
il attendait le train comme nous et je
me retourne et je vois un monsieur
étrangler mon fils par derrière du coup
le stranguler et ça a duré très très
longtemps si voulait pas le lâcher donc
heureusement que j'étais avec un ami qui
a réussi à le à le faire lâcher parce
qu'il voulait pas lâché du tout pas dire
voilà ils s' dorm ses paupières étaient
en train de se fermer et il m'a dit par
la suite j'ai j'ai très peur j'ai cru
que j'allais mourir j'étais en train de
m'endormir vous étz là vous là non moi
je suis une amie c'est moi qui aé la
vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux et qui l'
accompagné justement dans ces démarches
et ils ont mis très longtemps avant de
se présenter policiers euh ils nous ont
dit stop arrêtez parce qu'on du coup on
est on se défendit comme on pouvait euh
c'est la police là ils ont sorti leur
brassard orange et leur bombe
laacrymogène pour nous expliquer que
c'était la police et tous les policiers
en uniforme du coup de
la de la gare sont arrivés et ils nous
ont un peu bloqué contre le mur donc
après ce qui s'était passé j'étais
hystérique je voulais marcher prendre
l'air reprendre mes esprits parce qu'on
est jamais prêt à vivre une agression
comme ça surtout de la part d'un d'un
d'un policier en civil sur un enfant
surtout surtout sur un enfant et qui et
surtout un enfant qui est déjà blessé on
voit sur la vidéo qu'il a un plâtre
ouais donc voilà et en fait l'histoire
c'est qu'il il sont pris à votre fils
ils l' on mis les monotes non non non
juste étranglé enfin ils ont étranglé
ils ont pris votre fils pour un pick
pocket c'est ça voilà donc ils les ont
finis au sol tous les deux
incroyable votre fils comment il a réagi
à ce momentl parce qu'il pauvre il a dû
être il a il a eu très peur on croyait
que c'était un SDF toxico qui qui qui
était en manque de quelque chose on n
pas compris on a eu très peur on
s'attendait pas à vivre alors donc il
voulait quoi en fait il voulait juste en
fait c'est quoi c'est au moment il il va
dans votre sac juste pour prendre du
chocolat en fait et voilà donc il a
juste ouvert la pochette et il a refermé
instantané
il a rien pris sur eTTH voilà les
policiers se sont excusés et alors
justement les policiers sont rendus
compte de leur erreur ils vous ont dit
quoi ben ils nous ont dit on est désolé
mais à 100 m on n pas vu ouais à 100 m
on a pas vu ce qui se passait puis vous
vous parliez pas donc on a on pensait
pas qu'il était avec vous mais en même
temps on vient de faire 6h de train face
à face on a plus on a plus rien à se
dire alors sur les sur les il y a a
votre il y avait le le beau-père du
petit qui s'est agacait de la situation
qui est devenu virulent avec les
policiers c'est ça euh bah ils savaiit
pas ils savaient pas encore que c'était
les policiers non non quand ils se sont
présentés policiers c'est rien passé
c'était juste avant puis qu'on pensait
voilà que c'était un SDF et heureusement
qu'il était là parce que toute seule je
sais pas ce que j'aurais pu faire euh
sur les conseils de de ilem vous leur
demandez leur numéro d'identification
rioo c'est ça et ils ont refusé en fait
ils ont refusé de le donner ce qui est
illégal et euh vous vous allez vous
allez porter plainte oui il y a une
plainte qui a été déposée oui d'accord
ils se sont excusés après les policiers
ils sont excusés mais ils ont pas
réconforté l'enfant c'està- direire que
ça a été juste à la maman ils se sont
excusés l'enfant n'a pas été réconforté
il est encore traumatisé là quand il est
arrivé à la gerre du Nord je suis parti
les récupérer il était très mal il a dit
encore ici donc il est vraiment très
choqué en ou alors c'était en fait une
opération de sécurisation de la Gard du
Nord il y a beaucoup de problèmees Gard
du Nord donc ils étaient là pour lutter
contre la délincance et notamment les
vols à la sauvette et des policiers en
civil avaient cru repérer en votre fils
un délinquant un pck pocket donc je ne
justifie pas du tout mais j'explique ils
ont cru qu'il prenait ils se sont
précipités c'était la BAC et c'est vrai
que la violence de l'interpellation
paraît disproportionné mais eux se sont
dit enfin on démentait l'impossible gang
parce qu'il y en a plein Gard du Nord
donc ils se sont jetés sur votre enfant
et c'est vrai avec une brutalité qui
paraît disproportionné ça on ne peut pas
le nier et pour le moment les autorités
policières réagissent très mollement
vous l'avez dit une plainte refusée je
crois que vous avez écrit au procureur
c'est ça tout fait oui oui la plainte a
été envoyée directement alors il y a mes
amis
enfin il y a Bro Pomar qui me dit du
calme les bque trqu les P pocket toute
la journée et la gare du Nord est un
spot de ce type d'infraction les parents
pensent que le flic est est un SDF et
les flics pensent que c'est un pic
pocket oui bien sûr la B était là en
civil et puis il étent là pour faire
leur boulot mais là il y a quand même
une surréaction ou est-ce qu'on a le
droit de dire quand même que au-delà de
ça même si c'est un vrai pil pocket et
qu'il a 11 ans on étrangle pas jusquà ce
qu' ferme les yeux on a le droit de le
dire ça ou c'est
interdit policiers est-ce qu'il
reconnaissent qu'ils l'ont
étranglé non tu vois pas qu' on voit pas
qu'il est on VO qu'il est mal on croit
un enfant de 11 ans quand il te dit
qu'il a failli mourir qu'il a les yeux
qui se ferment même si c'est un pil
pocket de n'importe quelle nationalité
n'importe je m'en fiche tu fais pas un
enfant
de C le fléo et notamment à la gare du
Nord ce sont les mineurs isolés et donc
c'est ça problème qu'on peut pas savoir
tout de suite si ce gosse est un mineur
isolé s'il a sa maman à côté ou son papa
on peut pas imaginer maintenant la
violence de de la police zéro là c'est
c'est c'est pas bien alors juste pour
vous avez décidé de donc de porter
plainte pour usage de la force
disproportionnée et agression
injustifiée sur un mineur on a refusé
votre plainte oui dans le commissariat
de mon quartier et le commissariat
central également pourquoi on vous a dit
quoi pour quelle raison on ne porte pas
plainte contre on prend pas de plainte
contre nos
collègues comment il va votre fils
aujourd'hui bah il est il dort il se
réveille très tôt à 5h du matin est
réveillé euh qu il vous en parle tout le
temp ça va maisand je pense qu' il cache
bien les choses pour pas m'inquiéter
mais vous avez vu un médecin on a vu une
neuropsie qu'est-ce qu' faut faire il
faut faire un une ordonnance quelque
chose hein ouié fait ça a été faité il
vous a dit quoi le neuropsie bah qu'on
va commencer une thérapie pour en pour
en parler d'accord super euh alors je
tiens à dire c'est c'est vraiment un un
épisode très très malheureux hein cette
affaire on pense très fort à votre fils
bien entendu voilà et on pense qu' on
espère qu'il va il va se remettre de
tout ça et c'est vrai que ça fait du
tort aux autres policiers qui font pour
la plupart leur travail à fond on un
travail formidable on l'a vu encore tout
à l'heure avec l'affaire dont j'ai parlé
et c'est vrai qu'au en ce moment la
police elle est sur les dents et elle
essaie de voilà tous les fronts et c'est
vrai que le le il faut pas aussi ils
sont sur tous les fronts et parfois ils
font des des des des 24 24 et ils sont t
aler ils sont en alerte maximale et
c'est vrai qu'il y a des problèmes
d'effectif il y a des problèmes de
moyens et forcément parfois il peut
avoirpage dérapag pas non je voulais
savoir si il y avait une enquête de
l'IGPN la police des polices qui qui
avait été diligenté demandé alors j'ai
fait une une un signalement sur la
plateforme igpn ils m'ont demander
quelques informations complémentaires et
j'ai pas de réponse j'attends parce
qu'il vont être audiciux ces policiers
parce qu'on m'avait dit au commissariat
central que justement j'allais être
reconoqué par l'IGPN au commissariat
mais je ne pense pas que ça va se passer
comme ça quelles ont été les
explications des des policiers c'était
juste comme ça pardon on s'est trompé ou
est-ce que vous avez pu échanger un peu
plus avec eux oui bah j'ai honnêtement
j'étais pas en étage j'avais pas du tout
envie de discuter avec eux à ce
moment-là mais ils nous ont dit que à
100 m ils ont pas vu alors je comprends
pas ils sont une équipe de plusieurs
pourquoi ils envoient pas une personne
devant plus près que 100 m peut-être à
10 m pour pour observer si c'est bien un
pick
pocket là c'était c'était un peu du
travail bé c'était vous avez vous avez
vous avez été ils ont été cool avec vous
après ou pas du tout non non pas du tout
ils m'ont empêché du coup d'aller
prendre l'air et lorsque en fait je me
sentais oppressée je supporte pas d'être
d'être oppressée avec 15 policiers
autour de moi milliers de gens devant le
par de la G du Nord qui m'observve comme
si j'étais j'étais une délinquante alors
que je suis la victimes enfin on est
nous sommes les victimes euh non non ils
sont pas du tout excusé et quand j'ai
voulu partir parce que j'ai tout fait
trop il y a un policier en uniforme qui
a tenté de me mettre un coup de genou et
c'est mon c'est mon ami qui a qui a reçu
le coup au niveau des parties donc dans
l'INE c'est vraiment c'était c'est pas
passé
loin mais non on na pas très bien été
traité par la suite bon écoute en tout
cas on va suivre cette affaire avec
intérêt et on pense surtout nous à à
votre fils et on on lui souhaite
établissement P il nous regarde juste à
côté il est cé lu fait un gros gros
bisous voilà en tout cas on espère qu'il
vaer mieux parce que c'est lui
l'important le plus important c'est lui
et on pense très très fort à lui on
espère qu'il va pas être traumatisé euh
voilà parce que ça peut être extrêmement
traumatisant pour la pour l'instant il
est malheureusement il est il a peur de
la police il a très peur ils sentent
mieux et je sais que vous faites le le
maximum merci d'AV